shane is with us in cincinnati hi shane
how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
well i'm 22 and uh recently married and
my wife and i are on
baby step number two and we're wondering
if we should
use the money that we have saved to buy
a rental property
to beef up our annual income and attack
the debt then
or to use the money that we have saved
now
and just go all in right now
how much money do you have saved shane
um
about 16 000.
no under no circumstances
you wanna know why yes you put fifteen
thousand dollars on a rental property
you're not gonna make any money
by the time you pay the payment after
the rent you have expenses you're gonna
lose money every month
you don't have enough equity in the
property to actually freak and create a
cash flow
it's an illusion dude you need to stay
away from get rich quick channels on
youtube
[Music]
okay so let me tell you what let me tell
you what happened to me okay
i graduated from college at 22 years old
with a degree in real estate
and i worked for real estate company for
a little while and i started buying and
selling real estate
all borrowed money with almost no money
down like you have
almost no money i was broke when i
started
and with all borrowed money i bought
properties like crazy
and by the time i was 26 i had four
million dollars worth with a little over
a million dollar net worth and i was
making 200 000
a year doing flips and then rentals i
grew a portfolio
but i had almost no money and a lot of
real estate
the bank got sold to another bank and i
spent the next two and a half years of
my life losing everything
i owned because i did with
extra zeros on the end what you're
talking about doing
uh and now i own hundreds of millions of
dollars of real estate
you know 30 years after going bankrupt
and i paid cash for every bit of it with
wealth that i built and it has made me
even wealthier
real estate is something to make you
wealthier it is not something to
put fifteen thousand dollars down and
make a monthly income on
you're going to make a huge mistake if
you keep going down that path there is
no
shortcut in this process
okay that makes sense to you at all yes
yes yeah and let me tell you let me tell
you something else
you said you're married yes your wife
thought this was a dumb idea didn't she
um actually she's the one that
thought of it hello
okay i'm sorry i threw her under the bus
all right
i'm a little shocked okay well here's
the thing here's what
happens in our culture um
and it it happened to me um and
the way we grow up and see if this
sounds right to you we all
if you grow up without money which i
grew up without money and i'm kind of
thinking you did shane
okay okay we're looking at these people
with money
and they all seem to have real estate
and so we think then the connection that
we make in our brains because we don't
know any better because we didn't grow
up around wealth
is that real estate is what made them
wealthy
and uh actually the data that we have on
millionaires says
that very few people become millionaires
with real estate now here's what they do
do they do buy a lot of real estate as
they become wealthy and it makes them
wealthier
but very few people start from broke
doing real estate deals become wealthy
and retain the wealth because they're
usually have so much debt that there's
actually no cash flow
lots of risk and one little hiccup one
little covet gets loose
and um you know
and you get all kinds of problems and
you you'll end up in a worse
situation and so um there there's quite
a
um a movement happening among people
your age shane
that says real estate is the way to get
rich starting your own business is the
way to get rich
when in reality you can start your own
business if you want
uh you spend a few dollars and make a
bunch of dollars if you want with a lot
of hustle
uh but but uh but real estate usually
you should buy
later on in your wealth building process
and it accelerates
what the wealth you've already built but
very very few people statistically
become wealthy
from nothing starting with and only
using real estate to do it does that
make sense ken
it makes total sense shane here's the
deal uh young married couple
i would be working a lot of more extra
hours you want more income get a better
job or work
another job and that increased income
gets you through baby step two faster
you move into baby step
three and now all of a sudden you get to
a point if you walk the baby steps out
you guys could be there and you could be
saving up money then buy your first
house
you could have your house paid for and
buy your first rental by the time you're
30.
in cash if you just start walking these
baby steps and working your way out hold
on i'm going to send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover
and show you what we're talking about
you read it and then you decide for
yourself